[Applause]
[Music]
is we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway click on
the link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana
waala brothers and sisters and dear
friends Allah subhana tala has created
every single human being with certain
traits and attributes which is Mercy
anger emotion and other qualities that
we have and this is across board in this
video you see a Irish woman on her
wedding day leaving that and joining the
protest for pro Palestine here is the
footage
is and what's happening so guys Subhan
Allah just imagine for a second Subhan
Allah this is a non-muslim woman and
this is why it's so important for us to
never ever judge anybody yes never ever
judge anybody sometimes you look at
certain non-muslims they have better
qualities in the sense of the way Their
Manners are the way they carry theel W
how appreciative they they are and many
other elements so much so that some
Muslims don't even have those qualities
of course Muslims have toed and the
believe in the one true God Etc we're
not talking about that but for her to go
and leave her wedding day and join well
it shows us and that's why in Islam
Islam is just because in Islam we do not
believe that non-muslims are all going
to go Hellfire we believe a Christian a
Jew a Hindu a Zionist or whoever for
that matter has a chance of going
Paradise how we know the Hadith of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him who
said that those people who have not
heard the message of Islam on the day of
judgment will be brought to God and
Allah will bring the Hellfire and indeed
it will look like a Hellfire but it is
indeed paradise and God Almighty will
ask them to jump in and that will be
their test because we had a test in this
life and we passed it for those who did
not hear the message of Islam or for
those who heard the message of Islam in
a distorted way or for those who had a
psychological issue which they couldn't
comprehend the message or those who
haven't reached the age of puberty or
died as a child these people will be
exempt and they would have this specific
test and as you can see brothers and
sisters sometimes you see individuals
with such amazing qualities that you say
Subhan Allah just imagine if they were a
Muslim how that would make them more
beautiful inshallah subh in character
and the way they carry theel subh Allah
but that's why the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him said I came for
nothing but to perfect good character a
Muslim should be someone of utmost
beautiful amazing character like the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
the best of character is what that you
have an amazing you have good manners
with your Lord that you don't associate
partners with him and then you have good
manners with the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him by following his Sunnah and
accepting him as a prophet and then you
have good maners with the people and
your community and your neighbors and
then you have good maners with yourself
by not indulging in sins that wrongs
yourself we ask Allah subhana tala to
guide this woman to Islam and her family
members the fact that she came out and
left her wedding how many Muslims would
do that on their wedding day how many
Muslims this is a very important
question we have individuals Subhan
Allah who barely can even boycott boycot
specific products they can't go without
having Coke or whatever for that matter
and just to touch upon this there was
some uh thing cir I'm just touching upon
this I want to make a dedicated video of
us watching Muhammad hijab debate and
some brothers and alhamd anyone knows
knows that I don't drink fizzy drinks
any for that matter alhamdulillah either
the free drinks were given with the
pizza that we ordered but Subhan Allah
you've got these individuals who've got
NE yeah hypocrisy in their hearts just
because they are backstabbers who
backstab Palestinians and laugh and joke
about boycotting just because they saw
the seven up and Coke Subhan Allah where
he was U watching the debate they are
now accusing us that we unpurposely
ordered and this what happens brother
and sisters when somebody has a NE when
somebody cannot boycott and takes a
matter of Palestinians so lightly and
like a job because they been sell out
because they can't condemn Israel
because they know why they go to the
level of accusing us that we go and buy
these product alhamdulillah anyone that
knows us will make good assumptions and
know that we would never on purpose buy
these products which we are aware of
that's all I want to say may Allah bless
you brothers and sisters inshallah till
next time and make Dua for this lady w
we ask Allah subh to guide her to Islam
what an amazing gesture from her to join
the Palestinian protest even on her
wedding
day Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you can